[Music]
it's time for Iggy's social study your
quick look at what the Stars are posting
online excited you know flipping out
star Jenni Pulos announced she's
expecting a baby number two which this
adorable pink while Molly Sims welcomed
her third child a baby boy as Fergie and
Josh Duhamel showed off their little boy
Axl on their anniversary vacay I look at
those two together and I'm like wow
amazing
Demi Lovato is also on vacation putting
her fit figure on display in a bikini
Plus Bella and gigi hadid wish to their
mama Yolanda a happy bday with some two
cute throw backs
we're still digging Ed Sheeran's it just
released new music and we have a lot
more to look forward to musician shared
his new album title and the full track
listing on Instagram it's a nice model
for me on his philosophy guca and thanks
to the 50 shades darker Instagram
account we know who is joining as a nand
Taylor Swift on the soundtrack
apparently Nick Jonas and Nicki Minaj
have teamed up for a duet get that
poppin we're also getting an ariana
grande John Legend collab before the
Beauty and the Beast soundtrack re
shared this studio selfie tagging John
and the movie I wanna let it be a
surprise
then there's Cara Delevingne who shut
down a Twitter troll telling her to get
a real job with a classy clap back
you